I this is harshil astana from tech
mahindra they are one of the largest
idea of sourcing companies from India
specializing in China great thanks for
the question and the question is what
you see is the distinguishing strength
in Latin America and how will this
strength wrote an impact development I
think it's a great question my dragon
and I clearly believe this is this
definitely is the decade for Latin
America and things have been long will
you about this forest Hartman reason I
say this is a few reasons one is it
stable government the net is under
control inflation is under control it's
a growing middle class a young working
population I guess the stars are aligned
and a perfect storm seems to be coming